son estas las escenas que se querían
evitar en el país la gente abarrotada
sobre los puestos de los mercados una
vez hecho el anuncio del confinamiento
de diez días una decisión reclamada
desde hace varios días por los médicos a
medida que los hospitales colapsan por
los casos de kobe 19 el presidente del
país finalmente se ha resignado el seno
cara no podemos permitirnos un colapso
de la economía del país rechazando las
medidas necesarias para que haga un
cambio que sorprendió a la población
frente a supermercados y gasolineras se
formaron filas de varias horas viendo la
situación en el país ese confinamiento
es una buena decisión pero bueno a mí me
preocupa porque no tengo un salario fijo
pero sí al menos hubiéramos sido
prevenidos unos días antes hubiera sido
más fácil ir de la dne
alrededor de una cuarta parte de la
población del tri lanka está
completamente vacunado pero la variante
delta se propagó muy rápido según las
autoridades sanitarias oficialmente más
de 6500 personas han muerto desde el
inicio de la pandemia según expertos
independientes en realidad el número de
víctimas sería más del doble